love you oh I love you too hey John yeah
why don't we uh why don't we pull up the
live stream on YouTube and YouTube
machines yeah I guess we just do it on
the phone if it will work in who's here
who's hendo Zilla 98 what's up my friend
Ben Murphy 69 in the house Jimmy Neutron
you're the cutie my friend you're the
real cutie Lizard King 27 hey buddy hey
of course we know the source we notice
you nintendo uh Michael a what's going
on what it do know when im Michael a
I'll get my we're gonna as for you who
are here already we got 10 people in the
crowd we're gonna be Nintendo's Hilla
calm yourself Lizard King 27 he already
tipped us 50 bars menu my homeboy yeah
you my uh you mom you my Pussycat Doll
my friend you my [ __ ] cat daniel a you
look great my friend what's up to you
but Lizard King 27 he's our number one
fan right now so he's definitely most
special Jimmy Neutron appreciate the
likes is that like the witch-king of
Angmar yeah maybe we're gonna do some
movie news today we're going to talk
about some a few things and then you
guys can chime in as well and we'll take
your questions in between covering
stories and stuff so we'll kick it off
in just a couple minutes we're just
trying to make sure the YouTube is also
working give me one quick second to
check the youtube check your tubes of
the intimates I thought it is a series
of two algorithm tubes series Jude We
our lives hell yeah is what I will take
your questions you turn your radio down
let's not people on YouTube I see that
we are also on YouTube now yeah dick
joke oh wow does a lot of people on
YouTube hell yeah to change
a Purple Haze Pedro Rodriguez what's up
my homes dude what's going on everyone
okay since we got 54 people watching on
YouTube right now and we got about 10
people on you now we'll just keep this
stream off what's just kid let's go and
let's get it going so hey giant Presley
cool it's nice to meet you too Brendan
Cordero yeah we have a we having you now
such a you now okay so my first story I
want to talk about is not really a new
story but it's the fact that collateral
beauty is doing terribly so on his
office and with critics it's a Barlow's
Quran thanks for becoming a fan it's
doing so bad and this is Will Smith's
worst like wide release he's ever had in
his entire career oh boy I think it's
right after after her hey maybe it'll
get better once he gets China though
maybe it'll be a better 50 million more
to hell yeah but the it's just sad
because I feel like Will Smith doesn't
know how to choose doramas all that well
no you know I did like seven pounds
which is a much more serious role and
then he did than he did after earth
which was just not good and you know
he's got collateral I liked after earth
at the time and then and then I thought
about it I realize what everyone was
talking about it well I still don't
think it's eleven percent bad but it's
just it's pretty bad it's pretty bad the
designs are good and hey hey Ryan you're
my papi you mean Greg your by papi Sully
um so yeah I mean I just feel bad for
Will Smith guys because I mean sure yet
Suicide Squad but who really thinks it's
like oh that's Wilson it's movie what
I'm even that's mean that's a
problematic thing you know because that
movies is an arguable success at best
for him you know hmm and collateral
beauty I mean it's crazy because I got a
huge cast in there too i mean a yak here
nicely in there you
joe said john cusack john cusack Helen
Mirren isn't this is our do Dawson I
think is in this um I could be wrong
about that and we're Norton if Michael
Pena isn't it yeah Michael Pena my boy
yeah that's just too bad that it's uh
it's just not doing so well and it's
like I think will smith is a really good
dramatic actor but I just don't think he
knows how to pick the right drama the
only great drama I've seen the will
smith is the pursuit of happiness yeah
that's the only one missing only when
I've seen it oh there was that one movie
that biopic he did last year yeah yeah
yeah but there's a biopic he did last
year the football player with it yeah
yeah that was uh I was alright
apparently hey fans you now wants you to
remind you to share this broadcast let's
get more people here guys some Dara
broward he's gonna give you now right
now Kristen L how you doing Kristen you
look great r is fan you look awesome to
see that like Collateral beauty I was
bummed out because like I liked the idea
of it and the trailer made it look like
one of those movies that will just end
up being kind of ham-fisted at hallmark
e yeah it does it did it did feel very
uh lose a little too sentimental I think
yeah a little bit and then like there's
another movie that I was really hoping
would do well but it's just bearing very
poorly with the critics I'm I'm still
going to watch this film pastures yeah I
want to see it tell me when you go see
the thing is like I'm more interested in
it now cuz I I know that it's not doing
well well cuz i want to see why because
I'm something about this movie that I
didn't it's something didn't look like
it was gonna end up good to me when we
watch the trailer and like chris pratt &
and jayla together it's like it it's
like a mathematical combination and I
just don't I don't think I wanted to see
them in a movie together especially
movie set on a spaceship and perhaps um
so I'm curious as to what it's like it's
well I'm we're talking about passengers
guys with Jennifer Lawrence and Chris
Pratt I I just want to see Jennifer
Lawrence or Chris Pratt act together I'm
curious about it but I feel like they'd
be great together
I kind of don't why not I don't know I
feel like they're they both have a lot
of charisma they both have a lot of
charm it for some reason I can't picture
it between the two of them you know it's
like I feel like it's a match that
should work but ultimately won't for
some reason well I think we might see
Jennifer Lawrence's ass in this film I
mean that's cool that's another 13 for
sexuality and nudity as it stopped to
concerns of why it's pg-13 maybe we'll
see Chris Pratt's ass yeah well either
way I'm gonna be satisfied oh yeah
totally I mean I would look at Chris
you'll see Chris prices Prince presses
Chris praxis Chris Pratt's good Prince
crappy series although it is crazy
vinegary Chris Pratt's dick is what I
was trying to say his old I yeah I would
love to see Chris Pratt penis in a pg-13
sci-fi drama and how we do our live
streams for movie news is we talk about
movie newsle briefly and then we go and
look at the comments more somebody just
wrote in YouTube Jason Bourne was a good
movie and that's amazing as I agree with
you um alright i'm looking at you now
right now somebody says I am Legend in
men in black for their best for for Will
Smith but those are in trauma okay okay
arnis fan says what do you guys think
was Will Smith going down to downward
spirals he the next Nick Cage I don't
think it's like that's Nicolas Cage at
all I feel like no he just had suicide
squad this year and Suicide Squad did
fantastic at the box office despite what
you might think about the movie itself
it's still really performed incredibly
well see Will Smith seems like he's
still he seems still very invested in
his career like he's making choices and
stuff like that I feel like Nick Cage
has just sort of embraced just bouncing
from one movie to the next doing his
Nick Cage parody you know it doesn't
seem like Nick Cage cares as much as
Will Smith because i still get the sense
of Will Smith wants to do good movement
like Will Smith still tries yeah yeah
definitely like even that collateral
beauty thing he looked really depressed
I think he was trying to be sincere and
real I think what you said is probably
the truest is like I think he oh he
always brings his a
game and I think he just doesn't pick
them right yeah perhaps perhaps um hey
guys on you now I want to tell you guys
on you now that this you napping is
growing and it's awesome to see that you
know every time we hit number one on
movies as I think we're the only one on
you now who does movies so it's so cool
to see all you guys here and to have
everyone hear from you now chiming in
donating you guys are all great this is
katana she's got my back um what's uh
okay so and the other box office thing I
want to talk about is rogue one row one
has made a hundred fifty five million
dollars of the box office as you can
meaning Star Wars is definitely here to
say I mean there was literally no way
this was gonna happen but hey it's I'm
glad for them it's a terrific I mean
people were like doubting like I'm not
gonna do any spoilers for people were
kind of doubting that it wouldn't just
do as well as like they thought because
we lose no famous characters in it
that's why they were showing its traitor
in the trailers because they were alive
we need Darth Vader to be the present so
we can try to sell it I don't believe
that I i get i guess i get the the
arguments on paper but its star wars and
it's the first Star Wars spin-off like
everyone's gonna check that out you know
perhaps it's it it's still like Star
Wars just came back and force awakens
did really well and now it's a new Star
Wars movie so suit like like it's it's
Star Wars is beloved enough that people
just check it out because it's Star Wars
that's I still think that that's
absolutely true and everyone on you now
who donates thank you guys right now
John and I we met with our friend from
movie source Andrew his cousin Jason is
an audio engineer and he was telling us
like what equipment we should get to
make better live streaming services so
whatever you guys whatever bars you guys
donate today and you know a lot of that
is going to purchasing that when the you
now track comes in to be able to upgrade
our livestream equipment so we get
better audio we get hey I don't fake
just because I'm trying to look cool i
just like vaping brennan right why is
everyone so
he is just so anti everyone's so anti
baked these days or what I mean are you
babe you figure this is a big [ __ ]
deal cuz vaping is baby yeah whatever
but you know they have a noxious Li like
you're not one of those dudes is like
with like a big giant apparatus and like
glowing gems of smoke all over here when
I babe I also turn away from the person
I'm talking to and I like blow it the
other way you vape lexical just take a
look at you it's not on oh yeah that's
awkward you're staring at me while
you're sucking on something yeah all
right it's a weird which is like a
sucking on something as an activity you
have to think about and so like Craig do
circles those acne oh he wasn't close no
green oh I don't know oh you ever work
yeah you notice the new show new chair
hashtag circles oh whoa we did we just
got a couple of more bars oh yeah
harness fan thank you for helping
contribute to our goals here yeah we
just want to provide better quality for
y'all we're thinking of making this a
regular thing and if it's gonna be a
regular thing it deserves some
production value and because we also
like it when people come on to the
channel and when people come on we want
to make sure it's like we look like a
little bit more legitimate channels that
are just a laptop um shout out to your
friend Colin who vapes them okay Colin
you're a great guy you you babe like a
smoker you don't vape like a vapor
that's why that's why it's all right
Julie and Pena used to live in
california which part which part of
california did you live in and disney
marvel fan yeah we are giving you back
on the shimoda i'm actually just got
nominated for some Schmo down award as
like best something comp team
competition or something oh yeah do we
want we want I don't know if we've no
idea we didn't they weren't announced
yet but we are nominated hell yeah are
nominated I was an honor that was so
cool hey did you guys know about this
this news so John you man those
questions and I'll matta disk watch
these could be you now question right
now on YouTube em just wants to know
what we thought of the movie Snowden why
multiple people are like please review
Snowden's George age dive bars thank you
George haro is a Harris hardest George
50 bars that's that's enough to like
support you know like three families in
Africa right now but more importantly
it's going to help us get some
microphones to do this lot Easter even
the help us you know that you must feel
a little bit better getting through the
day um so did you guys hear about this
news David Bowie was considered for the
Gandalf role and Lord of the Rings says
the casting director I'm really glad
that didn't happen you yeah I feel like
that would have been distracting in a
way I feel like I would have been having
like a labyrinth flashback was watching
lord of the rings I would have I would
have been okay to N Sync was an attack
of the clones like George Lucas
originally wanted yeah that would have
been okay especially it's like a cantina
boy band and like yeah you moment like
it was perfect hey Kent big balls to
says Gandalf the gay wonder why he says
that John stop talking Ian McKellen is
known to be like the straightest guy in
the world actually uh he's so straight
hey Matthew mid d so tsys watching you
guys bright into my soul Oh Matthew
reading comments like that brightens our
soul and we don't have that bride of the
soul John and I live in dark turmoil
times you do alright we're living we
live in Los Angeles California where
it's all drugs and debauchery and
depression every word you look it's bad
yes really bad it's like it's like a
Todd salon so yeah I really do
appreciate you showing us some love my
friend all someone thinks I'm gay jon is
gay hmm John could be good i'll be a
great gay guy okay guys do you like I
I'm really good with having gay friends
greg did you watch the youtube questions
are getting nauseous someone asked a
Greg watches porn yeah Tommy Wiseau
asked that the guy who made the room and
I have a sneaking suspicion it's not
okay look I'll tell you guys something I
don't watch porn and
them the rare and the few time the rare
times i do i used to watch porn it will
be honest about that used watch a lot of
porn but i don't know i felt a lot like
i felt a lot of experiences and like
quitting porn and like I it started off
with like just talking about it about
wanting to like maybe I should not watch
porn anymore and then I went in and then
I like saw some TED talks and I started
reading some articles online and there's
like this big reddit thing about people
who are acquitting for him and I do
notice a big shift in my life whenever I
am not watching porn I haven't seen porn
for like quite a while now and feel bad
I do actually feel better when I'm not
watching it I feel like I'm sharper I
can focus better feel like I'm more
comfortable talking with women in
general not honestly man people are mean
on YouTube people would mean i'd read ly
way the people on you now are nice
radway bars want everyone to know in all
caps that I like anal everyone spread
the word uh so yeah spread that word if
you like annals actually just not my jam
but Roger esker 13 says what did you
guys think of Andrew Garfield's return
with hacks are rich I think it's awesome
that andrew garfield is like has a
Golden Globe nod for it and hacks are
rigid really well silence is getting
amazing amazing reviews right now I'm
just really happy cuz you know like
Tobey Maguire hasn't had anything after
spider-man that has been like something
to really capitalize on it but one thing
I saw the chubby Maguire did was a movie
called brothers and I thought he was
amazing in that movie but the movie no
one really saw that fell so it's really
cool that Andrew Garfield despite all
the spider-man shid that he had to go
through after amazing spider-man 2 as
spider-man 3 got can that he's able to
come back into an art form that he that
he's probably better suited for yeah I
know and I mean you know it's cool
because it's going to see him go back to
that kind of stuff especially cuz like
my first introduction to him I think was
in that terry gilliam movie yeah like he
came out of it out of stranger stranger
things for me but I liked his spider-man
you know and tell me where we are okay
uh who mother Medusa tube pointed out
that Toby where was the great gatsby no
one thinks Tobey Maguire we think
Gaetz me meti kinda racy but as laura
and dicaprio being cooled yeah I mean
like I like Tobey Maguire in that movie
but it it wasn't enough of a success to
be like Tobey Maguire got got one you
know okay I think he's really really
funny on the spoils of Babylon though
which again wasn't like a big thing but
it was like an IFC series that he's the
lead in that will fare on adam mckay
produced and like he's hilarious well
i'm pretty sure Tobey Maguire was the
highest-paid actor to ever be in
spider-man totally for spider-man 2 in
spider-man 3 so I'm pretty sure he's
gonna be alright I'm sure Tobey Maguire
is fine and he does he's not worried too
much and what matters most to something
better will always have the stamp is the
first movie spider-man you know and
that's something that's awesome total
darkness fans's toby is a new Brendan
Fraser do that I can see that happening
on for virender Fraser let's move on to
the next story that we have bookmarked
here there's this movie that Warner
Brothers has called geo storm it's a
Gerard Butler film about a man who goes
into space and prevent climate
controlling satellites from created a
man-made storm of epic proportions and
there's also a subplot involving an
assassination attempt on the president
that's the United States but now they're
going through like crazy risha up the
reshoots with like with a new director
the guy who directed this alone Judge
Dredd and they're like adding in so much
stuff so it sounds like it's just going
to be like it's bent this bent on the
shelf or I think about two years now
yeah and I just don't know why they
still have faith in this thing as if
it's actually gonna successfully go
somewhere you know yeah I just don't
feel like this film can possibly be good
now and I feel like once you get into
this situation you should go back to
your first cut and just release whatever
feels the most like it like it's what
you shot the first time yeah cuz like
Gerard Butler man I feel so bad cuz I
like him but this sounds like some [ __ ]
gerard butler would and it would wind up
involved true get a true hey um the
brendan v says about time for an axe
movie about the climate change uh
interstellar yeah and also there's one
that's like a [ __ ] well movie I don't
remember it came her out it came out
around the same time that flight of the
Living Dead came out it's on oh you're
thinking of wes craven's new nightmare
that is not it's all about climate yeah
oh hey okay Michael a is like desperate
on you now to hear our thoughts about
Logan what up dude Logan looks amazing
I've heard Logan is uh the the best
x-men movie for everyone who I know
who's seen it heard it's amazing which
one x-men origins no Logan yeah now
x-men origins is second best yeah right
after Logan yeah and I'm top three you
know with a cig accident origins is very
underrated you know yeah definitely
x-men origins was uh I thought it was
very monumental film the x-men franchise
and it's too bad more people don't
appreciate it yeah see where he [ __ ] up
the old peoples bathroom like I got some
real good chuckles okay it wasn't funny
I was moved oh so are that old man died
yeah he did everyone knows that guy's a
kid yeah that's how he got the jacket we
didn't need to know where he got it from
the Brent Brendan visas day after
tomorrow was the climate change movie it
was yeah yeah you know what rhombus like
geo storm film would Gerard Butler so
much you're our Butler for a second I'm
gerard butler every time I talk I'm my
face is over here it's not a secret that
we touch each other at night we do we do
that well gerard butler is our brother
you know I did I couldn't I couldn't
tell whether or not this guy would have
a thriving career after 300 it was
difficult to tell cuz 3 Anna's a very
specific film yeah he has all the quotes
and stuff but I'm like this I don't know
if we want to see him do anything else
hey man and he's tried other things
olympus has fallen was well received I
don't really like that film I liked his
parts in it though like like the thing
about drug putler for me is like I like
him and I think he's got a lot of charm
oddly enough but is he's just every it
seems like a he's a guy who's kind of
has a bad choice in movies yeah his
films are either not well received or do
poorly at the box office like there's
like you know like like 90s style action
[ __ ] like you know Oh emphasis fall kind
of felt like that to me or or gamer you
know yeah sort of pulpy action flicks or
like strange romantic comedies I mean
Daniel i pointed out law-abiding citizen
which i did think he was really cool in
the film itself wasn't that well
received didn't make that much money and
that's my point minus our Butler's he is
it a lot of like good film like no 300
and lip is falling I'm soon to be his
only two hits he's ever had yeah like
the ones that have done really well and
there was a time where he was doing like
a lot of romantic comedies is 27 dresses
the Bounty Hunter PS i love you and it
was like why are you the wrong calmly
down yeah it seems like they tried to
put him into like the Hollywood leading
man mouldin like it's not i don't think
this would your Butler belongs like you
don't worry think I don't think that's
where his skills are best suited you
know what I think it might have gone
wrong for Gerard Butler he never stayed
anywhere near as cut as he was at 300
and I feel like that might have worked
against him well and he was also like
the the buffest dude ever in that movie
like that was the first yeah we were
like holy [ __ ] actors got buff yeah but
Gerard Butler like it wasn't long after
that word yeah he's still strong sales
sealer but he's not like it's not like
super singing shredded you say he needed
a t-shirt scene like in every marble we
were like they take the shirt I do it
wow I feel like when actors like come
onto the scene and become famous for
something for like stuff like that it's
hard for them to still maintain a career
if they don't keep up that kind of sexy
image sometimes well you know Matthew
McConaughey's you have the McConaughey
still incredibly talented yeah but he's
also still super sexy buff yeah yes you
know and he's got that never lost that
he's never lost that I can see Gerard
Butler one day scoring a
a Matthew McConaughey turn around if he
plays his cards right right right just
come back and randomly do a terrific
movie he needs a terrific movie he does
I think he deserves it i think it's a
good a sure are but like I don't think
he can do American accents though no
cannot can't do he just can't i'm at a
low biting citizen I'm a law-abiding
citizen uh what what else is on here
okay let's go some questions here no
milk haze and Arab Brower says where's
Hank off to and Incredibles to hancock 2
is probably stuck in the lack of success
for hancock one well i thought one was a
major success it made huge money made
lemon wrench money i just really happy
for arguing it didn't get great reviews
yeah and people were not happy with the
finale yeah but it was still like a
major if it still made a [ __ ] ton of
money and i like the like the first half
of hancock a lot more than the last half
of Chanukah i do too but I sort of feel
like because Hancock was such an uneven
movie and it did disappoint like it has
a disappointment tied to it and I feel
like that could have been enough to hold
up the production on them to not be like
let's rush back because you know there
is that Association attached to the
first Hancock in a very strong way true
you know I wish they would make a hand
[ __ ] too if they could make it work but
that's the thing is like I even me
thinking about it now like I don't know
they could um doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo missed okay so the
next story there's this Gus Van Sant
film starring Joaquin Phoenix called
don't worry he won't get far on foot
we're walking Phoenix is playing John
Callahan a cartoonist who made
controversial McCobb subjects and they
know there were met Rebecca Bray macabre
macabre and jonah hill and rooney mara
are expected to co-star in the film
with him at Jonah Hill it's interesting
what the career Jonah Hill has because
it is at the point with me with Jonah
Hill work he's in a Drama it doesn't
like weird me out yeah right yeah he
seems to be like the one guy who can
walk back and forth across the line at
20 stream comedy too yeah he's in the
drama I can accept that and then he'll
do a movie like war dogs where it's like
it's kind of close yeah exactly yeah I
I'm glad he's able to do that it's weird
because it was weird in the movie where
he and James Franco both did it yeah but
I don't like a lot of comedy [ __ ]
together yeah it's kind of weird to see
to do that it's like if you if you saw
to class clowns doing Shakespeare like
this is not not weird though but it's
gonna be my Joaquin Phoenix is my left
foot I hope she is gonna be is mean
walking Phoenix ounce yeah you're
walking Phoenix as a total weirdo on set
yes what I've heard it's a 30 centimeter
near fella but i I've loved him ever
since I walk the line yeah I've always
been compelled by him I lost interest
during the i'm still here days but but
he's always compelling to me and he's
always supernaturally I feel like I'm
still here would have been great if he
was more famous and then he did that
yeah he was more like a monumental life
stature like yeah what an Oscars he's
never won an Oscar really know you got
gin for walk the line needing an homage
I remember you were mad about those very
mad that was a year that Capote wanna
[ __ ] Capote yeah I like them it's all
about cash it's all it's all about the
Johnny the cat hold hard johnson cash
are you excited to see why him George HS
no no I'm like a pretty funded that's
what brian class addage [ __ ] James
Franco come together for this is too bad
man I mean James Franco Bryan Cranston
gonna be like an awesome drama together
the area is doing I was Malcolm in the
Middle kind of comedy yeah yeah I'm like
cuz i struggle with James Franco right
now cuz I guy I only really lose
into like really comedic role just can't
tell when he cares yeah exactly and like
I would have been really psyched to see
them do a drum together do something
that was more on the serious edge yeah
because this just looks like they didn't
need to be in this neither than this we
could have done this comedy with two
other actors yeah you know um I don't
know Mike it might be fine I don't need
it reviews out free yet I look it looks
like one of those movies where they
won't put out reviews until like the day
of I mean I imagine it'll be no I think
it's got a 44 right what why him has a
44 yeah I feel like it would be still
like any number of those comedies to me
is usually like amusing a little bit you
know especially if I if I liked it just
lifts all going it's got 41 ok open it's
from John Hamburg oh that's right yeah
he's a guy I did I Love You Man oh it
might be all right then I love that I
love you man I loved I Love You Man 2
and then we didn't get a tremendous
tomatometer score now definitely not
forty-one percent yeah are we excited
for animal to kind of what movie and a
belt to the one did the lights out guys
doing I'm pretty excited for that yeah I
hope he can do for weed you what we'd
you two did for him hey Roger ester 13
wants to know the best Rogen Goldberg
true movie um I would have to say I
think superbad is their best I think
yeah cuz superbad has like a really
really kind of heart film that I feel
like me super Bad's the one that could
really stand the test of time well in
super 8 yeah cuz like that that movie
that scripted that exists like when they
were still teenagers yeah I started
writing that so like yeah it has all of
that richness you know yeah I would
definitely die like the rest are really
fun of their good additions to that
catalog but super bad like I that movies
attached to a time in my life and this
is the end is a very special film too
it's certainly unique I think that think
it's special like it's the first time
they managed to do that like get a bunch
of actors to play themselves and like
yeah idly do celebrities
at tyre tunics full extent and they
honor the apocalyptic genre yeah like
James James Franco and Seth Rogen that
whole crude like they have managed to
come into the film landscape and like
set up a thing you know oh yeah to have
to leave it impacts like they've had an
impact and I think Green Hornet's a
little underrated I want to see that
like I agree hard it's a little
underweight little I'm sure like I'm
sure I'll get why the response was so
Luke but like it's Michel Gondry him
like yeah and I thought it was like cool
action in it and Seth wrote like the
biggest complaint I saw was how like
Seth Rogen's The Green Hornet he's not
really like a hero in a yeah it's kind
of an [ __ ] who makes bad decisions
all the time but I thought that was
funny I thought it made fun of the fact
that like would the show The Green
Hornet that won't give a [ __ ] about the
greenhorns about catos old honestly yeah
like as our people wanted I think in the
Hong Kong they called it the Cato show
like I just don't I don't think that it
was a bad choice to make hit the green
hornet character a shity nud yeah but
make a toast ill awesome cuz when the
movie was dumb people were like yeah
green orange such a kale is really cool
no well I thought there were another
recapitalizing on that and making fun of
that yeah that's what is a I mean that
sounds reasonable to me I thought it was
cool we gotta watch let's watch it i
wanna watch now let's see if I was you I
am Noah Flores asked if I'd like to see
a neighbor's three yeah you know
neighbors to was one of the best
comedies I saw all year and I was really
delightfully surprised especially for a
sequel with a but the various
Pacific kind of premise first one give
us something very familiar but at fresh
freshness to it I thought was great and
I loved how neighbors who got even more
got more bits like sociological point of
views and perspectives in the world on
it so yeah top you naspers pretty evans
with with one red crown is here what is
a red crown what's a red crown people
dislike sakata thrown [ __ ] right now
isaiah hort says we're very funny oh
thank you okay really I don't know it's
subjective man i'm mostly feeling like a
little bit off today like hazel off most
john and i went to the show last night
what was it called blood alley blood
alley at zombie joe's in north hollywood
and i had no idea what this was i had no
[ __ ] clue i just went with john i
thought it was gonna be like some play
we were about to watch but then it was
like this Peter where this a lot of the
rows are on one side that people are
also sitting on the like chairs on the
floor and then they'll do it is like a
rectangle yeah that just has like a
riser or what evolved around yeah it's
like theatre of the square and uh it was
like a bunch of Vidya pets of like her
themes that are taking place on
Christmas the New Year's holidays and it
was really creepy it's really creepy and
disconcerting it up on guard and weird
way I didn't know that they do shows
like that were that much nudity goes on
this is very end this will exact a lot
of just flat-out completely naked people
nice guys and girls yeah this was a lot
more sexual than I went to her bit death
back in the day which is like their
flagship horror show and it's that one's
actually he's a lot more like unsettling
and scary and uncomfortable than this
like this one had like a black humor
throughout yeah I was expecting it to be
so so bare yeah there was like a lot of
nudity a lot of dicks ass vagina boobs
is all there all I kind of love expiry
like that because it is like when you
find yourself watching a show like that
like it is unique you remember this
extreme it's not like the counting your
at all the time you know I always really
relish those yes I'm like this is
completely different than what I'm used
to so fun yeah it was fun I'm definitely
not gonna forget that I love that kind
of so I'm not gonna forget all the
nudity either a lot of great nudity
there a lot of wonderful and wonderful
nudity I mean it's those guys who got
naked are very fortunate to have like
rather big penises too I'm sure because
if you're gonna get naked and share your
dick you don't want to have a small
penis I don't think yeah like if we were
more comfortable with male nudity in
general I don't think we care so I'm
definitely a grower not a shower really
Oh when I'm hard I think I look great I
think I look amazing Thank You Sammy hey
we got a cool question you know yeah
he'll do you have any ideas for the last
MTU or GCE would be yes the last times
one the last MCU movie should be the
punisher kills the marvel universe
that's me and then the DCE you maybe
should be deadpool kills DC Universe way
tipples marble then I know that's what
will make it wow that's what imaginary
they marvelled her Fox Fox I would love
it if DC oh he's like I know how to get
back at Marvel Studios will work with
[ __ ] summer movies will bring the
Fantastic Four in x-men and all that
meant to the DC will even bring Sony
into the next oh that would be that
would be crazy they had DC DC if Warner
Brothers was like let's work with Fox
and get the Reds that would be nutty
happy now you ready clusen movie likes
to give a weird showdown at the ok
corral of superhero movies um on a
Stanley move if you did the last time
see movies like a weird betta like
fantasy about like it's a biopic of
Stanley that has like a superhero movie
inside of it actually funny well that is
what they're doing they're they're
developing a Stanley biopic right now
that is supposed to be like that you
you gonna have a caning I'm not sure a
maybe you want a guest what does that
mean two guests what does that mean to
guess I still don't understand some you
now terminology guys any questions on
YouTube um let me see Lincoln more
boobie news will come in tomorrow and
this is news apparently John put it best
news that there will not be news Captain
Marvel director won't be announced until
2017 I know exactly you should write
Captain Marvel denis villeneuve agile um
that could be cool duck dennisville
Annette I I think I think we I think he
would not sign his name I think he would
create the best superhero film I feel
like you can make a good superhero julie
as they let him do his thing Julian Pena
said I found this channel after seeing
greg doing some monologue on the street
and now he's following me here and yeah
i do monologues on the street the next
person who donates bars i'm going to
improvise a poem for you to show you my
kind of monologues psychopath asks if we
listen to rob zombie and watches movies
we do watch the Rob Zombie movies we did
a whole review of 31 for our halloween
segments to go back and find that a huge
rob zombie fan what does it mean to
guess some why don't get how that works
like they would be in the chat with us I
guess next person generated bars gets a
uh it's a it's an improvised poem from
John and I ok that's what we give cuz
we're a movie channel that's what we do
Phoenix green guru wants to see Lily
live long enough to see the walking dead
end will live long enough it watch The
Walking Dead begin in real life that's
also true that's exciting you know I'm
ready for the apocalypse no you're not
I'm ready for the Apollo how come on we
don't have to worry about money true
yeah I should have to worry about these
the other things we just have to worry
about taking care of one another and
surviving and we give action
I don't know we'll probably go back to
the days of like you know like the
medieval times well barter with food and
goods will trade our women's trade our
women and children serve the boys to the
White Walkers we will kill it cast aura
what question quite weird question do
you plan on dying your hair me are you I
I will never die by her Oh totally yeah
i mean this used to be like a blue and
now it's this coral thing somebody says
what's up Julian Salinas says what's up
grade you make chai Rome cry I love
making Tyrone cry yeah I think Tyrone's
a little baby oh I want all you guys
comment on Tyrone xvideo that Greg says
your baby you're a [ __ ] Tyrone's a big
fat capital P [ __ ] tell him that it
said that random really won't return my
calls and it's upsetting me random
rookies on YouTube asks do you all have
a problem with Justice League to being
pushed back making way from movies like
gotham city sirens and Deadshot what do
we have a problem with them pushing back
Justice League 24 gotham city sirens and
dead shot and stuff like that yeah what
because all i want is to see them all
together i don't care for these
standalone films I don't care to just
see all these other characters first and
then you bring them together in one
awesome movie I think we shouldn't care
for anticipate your friend ovation on
yes [ __ ] that stitches that shove them
all into one movie and just throw in
some expositional backstory so we know
who they are let's get all this
adventure together people I think DC
knows exactly
and never change I'm sort of but you and
I don't have a problem with them pushing
it back cuz like on the one hand i'm
like yeah it seems weird to make your
second big group movie right after the
first bit movie but at the same time
like why are you pushing all the way for
dead shot and gotham city sirens well
because a Will Smith probably is like I
won't do as Suicide Squad to unless I
get my own Deadshot spin-off movie is
his this isn't sure yeah bet that's what
will Smith said I know will I would I
know Big Willie he turns that you that
one hundred percent he tends to be that
way it's big willie style nanny know
they don't want to lose David Ayer he
gave us the wonderful masterpiece of
Suicide Squad best and he also gave us
that one he gave a sabotage you have a
street kings hey man maybe they'll give
him like 12 weeks to write the next one
and it will be two times as good as soon
as soon as that's good Phoenix career do
you guys watch fear the walking dead no
no I liked the first season for the most
part I like the last like three episodes
for sure the second season I just I
couldn't finish it max couldn't finish
it is two and then I realized like it
just got to the point were like yeah
you're just trying to fill the time
until like the actual good show comes
around and I just I could wait instead
of watching this and ruining walking
dead a friend of mine described fear the
walking dead as the show you watch
because you watch The Walking Dead yeah
and when I I saw the first few episodes
and I kind of felt that way I was like
there there is stuff that's cool about
it when you're watching it but none of
that really stuck with me and like every
episode felt like it was just about to
get cool and then it would end and I
don't know I I just didn't feel the
desire to keep going a bar because I
like a lot of people involved our friend
Oh sold the boss you're gonna get your
poem in a second oh there was a are we
had a friend on the show named Lorenzo
who's not on the show but now he's on my
agents of shield is it a Camry occurring
character these like ghost writers
brother
oh damn dude Oh wheelchair that's cool
yeah and another friend of my mark kelly
is on your walking dead I've worked with
a couple they're not our friends anymore
now now that they've been on that show
well I want to see the show because of
that like I want to see their work but
like keeping up with a story like I
don't just want to skip ahead to get
there so I keeping up with stories tough
now and you have to choose like there's
so much TV that you have to choose and
when you don't get to watch much TV you
got it you got to be yeah yeah you
selected like the way it's like if it's
pretty much allows too much TV out there
you got to be careful with what you're
watching everyone on YouTube is saying
Mads Mikkelsen as the Joker you know
what I don't think so I don't want to
see him play another villain yeah I mean
I think he could do it but I'm like it's
it's another one of those things like
happened with um with bryan cranston or
eat yourself or it's like we like
somebody and then we gotta put him in
everything cool cuz they would be good
at it but honestly I want to see him do
some things I saying make Javier Bardem
the Joker like yeah Christoph Waltz the
jury exact them like I like those guys
too but now let's see what else did it
yes I get it like look college is asking
this question a lot have you seen hell
or high water I'm not yet but I think
it's on HBO now so i think i'm gonna go
watch it i really want to watch this
before Oscar seat for the Oscars rolled
around because I hear that's gonna be a
pretty big contender here it's awesome I
didn't know much about it I've heard
it's terrific okay sold the boss here we
go I once met a fan named sold the boss
he once sold the loss of a hundred bars
had to sell his cars he couldn't go very
far because he wanted to donate to the
real rejects something these rejects
would never forget and something that
they will never regret cuz they gladly
accepted his bars and they said John you
take over the phone or sold the boss no
I'm like your beatnik nor not be no you
go um the bars grew into a great gold
kingdom eldorado the road to that's
another movie
you can get on VHS golden nuggets all
right it's like oh the boss donating the
bars we're gonna give her a proper yeah
oh my can I can like write down in real
time and then read it out loud I'm not
gonna just like freestyle rapping so the
boss likes the floss no matter the cost
of his gums bleeding no matter how much
he's grieving he'll let those gums bleed
until he needs to clean his teeth cuz so
the boss is where I am so the boss I'm
Rachel you're my Ross ooh and can't get
better than that Ross ya can't get
better than that people you know that's
the best one that's the best run there
you go very icy I can I can I cricket
Iran your name's Sean writes poems like
he has to rezas yeah that's the first
time we've tried hard and so the boss
yeah we do have an inch I haven't
Instagram at the Greg Alva he has at
reasons to Jerry and oh my auntie no
movie favorite Tarantino movie oh that's
a Kill Bill or Django I love them all
don't worry I think they're all great
okay before you what about it yeah or
you start saying that [ __ ] no I like
them already but I would have to say
Django or kill bill I like his hero
tales yeah I do like his hero tales like
I know like you know Pulp Fiction
reservoir dogs or tend to be to go to
once but that one Django is is the most
moving one to me naturally like that's
the one that ain't like surprisingly I
feel really good when i'm done with the
film yeah well and and and that's a
really visceral movie cuz like is as you
know there's a big debate about that
movie and about like how problematic it
might be but like when i watch that
movie i'm enthralled by that yeah i saw
that twice at the new bed and by the
time it gets to the end where Django
like rises to succeeding in his revenge
and rescuing his lady as awesome if
it feels great and like there's so much
in that film it says it's an epicly it
was like three hours or something it's
an epic Slyke two hours and 45 minutes a
long movie but it's epic like what
starts off as a slave and it grows into
ultimate bounty hunter is awesome we
realize man and I mean like there is so
many moments of greatness in that movie
and and and like that's to me that's
still my favorite DiCaprio performance I
thing ever like Calvin Candie is a
villain of another level not the beach
the beach is a close second up Danny Boy
Oh Danny Boyle now the good beer though
good beard one kill bill to me is
definitely the most stylistic foam he's
ever done and it's also my favorite
female action lead I've ever had ever
seen on screen so I would definitely say
those two are my favorite like like kill
them it's weird to say I used to just
say kill bill cuz that's probably the
film I would I've watched the most out
of all of his films I've seen like
reservoir dogs with pulp fiction a [ __ ]
ton of times as well and Jackie Brown a
lot actually I've seen death Proof
probably like three times I don't know
how to choose what like the problem is
every time I try to choose one like a
case comes back up for one of the others
yeah because they all have their
different the other different things
about they'll have their Tarantino touch
but they're all different like right now
I might even say hatefully just because
like I really liked it in a particular
no oh wow i am from Switzerland the
thief L says i am from Switzerland my
whole family big fan of your videos and
I saw you in Swiss Film Festival please
at least react any southern indian tamil
movies like what like what sent it to us
on Facebook Oh dilla gamer says ghost
rider vs spawn who wins spawn spawn
spawn easily Brendan be bad manners or
Oh Batman what Zorro has a sword and a
horse that man just drives his Batmobile
through them dead yeah that would be a
less it was like a more time appropriate
version of Batman where they're more
evenly matched for the time they're like
Batman's got gadgets that [ __ ] it's over
I Phoenix greenberger says will there be
another funny Nemo spin-off finding
Marlin yeah it's sure I don't think so
Oh probably come on maybe funny Albert
Brooks maybe he starts seeing like some
fish therapist oh man hey like Annalise
fish exactly I think it'd be really
funny cuz Marlin has like he doubts
Allah he's skeptical he's he's as as he
is it's like constant fear he's a
terrified guy gets game putting these
like dangerous adventures and it's like
d by this point you shouldn't be such a
scaredy-cat anymore and so it's like I
want it I want to find out why Marlin is
the way he is Thank You Marlin right
yeah I want an origin story from Laurel
yeah a board game out before Tory secret
of the title is that Marlin is really
finding himself we do should be a
grieving story of Marlon getting over
his dead wife just make it a drama make
it like on those disease dramas yeah
exactly Oh pick the best
when there's a dead wife if they bring
movies because you're the ones that
really get you well Hugh Jackman died in
logan julia pet julia Pena 810 with Hugh
Jackman died Michael hey only wants to
talk about Logan oh yeah he's going to
die I promise you I promise you he will
die Julian Pena 8 160 for difference in
any movie reviewers and you guys that
watching you feels like talking with
friends about movies oh that's exactly
what we hope what do you mean guys I
feel like I feel like Jeremy Jahns is
more like what it's like talking with
with my friends my friends are always
right up here so i'll give you my face
and putting their hands up here but they
express and they all like move around in
my plane of vision it's weird and some
of them are just like chris stuckmann
poor very calm and reserved and but
they're very articulate and eloquent and
they're speaking but will crack the
occasional restrain joke yeah but you
know like they most of my friends really
think about what they're gonna say
before you speak listen my friends are
scripted or you know a lot of them are
like yeah you know John flick sir you
know they just get up in my face
hopefully hi I'm going to talk to you
about Rome one row row what here it is
and then they flex that's just the way I
think flick sir and Jeremy Jahns and
stuckmann there they're more like the
ones you feel like you're just hanging
out with you know mm-hmm no um we got to
end this soon guys cuz John has to go to
a show with his family cuz he loves them
and all that [ __ ] the holidays so that's
what this shirt is and I'm in heart
nerds this is a this is bleep called
breathing architecture it's a it's a
piece by a guy called alex pardee with 2
e's on the end he's a member of zero
friends and they're awesome and he did a
bunch of designs for sucker punch my
favorite Tarantino movie is actually the
scene with benicio del toro and clive
owen in Sin City my favorite Tarantino
film is his episode of CSI ooh
who out of the box choice there no well
let's hear it this is movie fights let's
hear your art or his conan episode i
don't know which one was better he
didn't write for conan we didn't he
directed somebody oh it was jimmy kimmel
or somebody he directed an episode of
somebody's late night talk show awesome
Goffin gave us a hundred likes Oh hooray
dude I I I think that way about like
we're on bikes bikes bikes bikes bikes
strikes strikes types like toys or small
children Pike yeah I Captain Pike or the
stick that you would put a head on or
yeah there's that like I will just say
one or two more questions that we're
gonna go Michael a favorite Scorsese
movie you guys ready for my favorite
Scorsese movie no oh god it's not going
to be good fellows it's not gonna be
raging bull somebody else for your janu
room not gonna be taxi driver okay
nevermind so I can be cooked them it's
at a pot of you [ __ ] [ __ ]
y'all a bunch of [ __ ] homos [ __ ]
quiz [ __ ] firefighters I think their
part is a very homophobic film now that
I hope I'm good well yeah they got the
departed is yes'm that's my that's my
favorite cuz the cool thing about the
departed is it gives you something
different from source AZ and the
familiar nisso source AZ that we love
but a lot of people will list like good
fellow seems to be the number one
Scorsese film that people it's magic it
is magic and it's a monumental mobster
flick for sure yeah I look I've seen
goodfellas numerous times as well but
departed gives us two movies in one that
blend
seamlessly to the point where you don't
even notice you're watching two separate
films this is true you're watching one
gangster movie about the Irish mob in
Boston and then you're watching a CIA
move you know about front leg that deals
all with CIA [ __ ] the whole time and
it's constantly cutting back and forth
and so you get a CIA film wondering
who's the snitch and we know who the
snitch is mm and then you're getting a
mobster film as well about this guy
going undercover I feel like there's so
much more elements and layers to the
departed that that he's never done
before and I didn't I didn't view the
departed as like a Lifetime Achievement
Oscar award like how they do sometimes
like you do yeah that's even like he
really I felt like you deserved it this
was the movie for you and some people
might say it's like a beat for beat
remake of infernal affairs if you've
seen infernal affairs you would know
it's not you just know I I saw I think
you look like two or three infernal
affairs movies I saw the first one and
like a lot of what happens in the first
one like so much of what goes on in like
the first 30 or 40 minutes happens like
to at like an hour and a half into the
departed in terms of plot points I think
it was a it's totally doing the people
who made infernal affairs weren't happy
with the departed because they were like
it's way too vulgar way to him Oh Sarah
la tarde look 3,000 since you are since
we're about to end it and i'm assuming
sara is a girl's name Sarah Lawford
captured a mullet are captured a moment
of the greg alba ooh who's somebody
likes a moment somebody likes the
moments of Greg hello Sarah I got a red
hot chili pepper waiting for you said so
do I'm you not an STD or something it's
just huh last question Coke or Pepsi
Pepsi Pepsi um sur la la charte 3,000
wants to know do you like home alone I
was weirdly thinking of this movie the
other day oh I like habla I do like home
alone I think it's
Joe Pesci's best work since good fellows
I'm cool with home alone and didn't love
it it's creepy to me well it's a total
creepy yeah yeah Hubble is really creepy
it's a week it's the weirdest Christmas
movie I can't see that movie as a comedy
I just can't like it doesn't coalesce
this home alone is the weirdest
Christmas movie because it's I'm like
I'm talking about like Oh daughter card
takes place on Christmas oh dear I mean
like this is considered a Christmas
classic about and it's a boy a boy who
gets left alone like his old family and
odd like engineering savant like you
already see his parents are neglectful
his older brothers are fully and he gets
abandoned and he's so happy about that
yeah I've made my family disappear like
it's as if it's awesome and then he just
tortures these guys and he's to
pedophiles try to like break it he said
of Reagan and [ __ ] uh and he just
tortures these guys like terribly
painful way it's a collector like that's
like a look and ice [ __ ] up glad I
don't think his parents ever found out
about what he did and doesn't happen
again yeah the same people but in New
York yeah it's like I know they miss
this side of their son's life it's not
Dexter's Laboratory office in New York
is creepy ins is like penguin pigeon
ladies not paying up the app pigeon lady
has like all these pigeons I'm missing
i'm joe Martinez creepy rumson wash
these classics sara is a girl thank you
Sarah for being a girl Greg loves the CW
flash I do love the CW flash John you
gotta get going to do alright guys we
got to end this Sarah your sounds so
sweet all you guys you guys are donated
sold the boss thank you so much my
friend never owned a harness Lizard King
arnis fan you guys are may
using I really a buttery while you guys
thank you for coming out look I think
YouTube as well we'll try think of more
special things to do to actually get
bars to make it more fun for you guys
I'll get better at rapping out loud yeah
what we'll think of something we'll
think of something next time what we'll
do is once we get bars you can take the
conversation for like five minutes and
I'll start like a nugget and then I'll
give it to you and then you can continue
the Nugget and there we go so it's like
a real poem with 2 e's for real reject
marketing and we love you Sarah we love
you Sarah I am going to be late love you
Sarah